Now, let's imagine that this program needed an object that
bears a resemblance to this gold one that we already made.
To achieve this, perhaps we could start by building a new object and
giving it all the same values stored at all the same keys.
We'll make a new object called blue and we'll start making it
look exactly like the gold object by copying the properties over one at a time.
Incidentally, there are helper functions out there that can help you copy all of
the properties from one object onto another.
It doesn't come with the language, but
you could imagine doing the exact same thing with a simple foreloop.
This arrow represents the process of copying over each of
the properties from the gold object to the blue object.
Now, although the effect of this copy operation on
the blue object will last indefinitely.
It's important to remember that the copying happens just at
one moment during the program's execution.
It is not an ongoing copying back and
forth behavior that keeps the two objects in sync.
In this case, there's only one property in our gold object, so
the copying process is quite simple.
The copying process is now complete and won't be repeated.
So if our program later goes on to modify gold or blue, we'd probably only
expect them to have the a property in common after those modifications.